unfortunately in many ways 70% of
illnesses on the planet all kinds are
self created if you keep yourself in a
certain way physically and mentally the
virus in the bacteria will not work the
same way as it works upon somebody else
the last 29 years I have not been able
to cancel one program because I'm
running temperature I got a cold I got
this I got that it doesn't matter what's
happening what you have to do you anyway
have to do if it's summer you still go
right now a lot of people don't go it's
a little hot outside they don't go and
work little cold outside they don't want
to work a little raining they won't go
and work at snowflake they will not go
and work this is just weather so for
every change in weather if you have the
comfort of cowering yourself in a
blanket and lying down once you create
that your body will learn to fall sick
as often as possible if you just keep it
this way it doesn't matter what it is
anyway I have to go and do what I have
to do you will see your body will just
bounce back as quickly as possible even
if it gets the worst kind of infections
so you just have to set the necessary
conditions for health both for yourself
and your children if you have them do
not set incentives for sickness when the
result of an event has no impact on you
both ways you blissed-out you are a
success when the fruit of the action
does not determine how you are you do
things because of the exuberance of what
you do then you are a success the result
may depend on variety of things results
are not always yours there any result to
happen whether it's in a game or in life
situations there various factors
involved not all of it is in our control
but what is in our control is either we
did our best or we did not do our best
that's in our control as long as we're
doing that and whatever the result
maybe if you are still blissed-out that
means you are a success because life
cannot defeat you anymore you just
watched two amazing clips from Sadhguru
take the next three minutes to sit
quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]